[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
77 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing very well.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
Very excited about a very cool
episode with Basecamp Networks.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
super cool episode.
Some people I met when
we were at Cloud Next
not too long ago, having a
great conversation about machine
learning and agriculture.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
sounds a little bit like,
if you remember, we had
this episode long time ago
with Descartes Labs, because
they were also doing things
with agriculture.
But this is actually completely
different than having
satellite images.
They use basically sensors
and cameras from your phone
directly to take
pictures and tell you
what's going on with plants.
It's really cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's
really, really cool.
After that, we're going to have
a quick chat about learning
resources for machine learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
They're all free.
MARK MANDEL: They're all free.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that's a very cool thing
if you have time.
That is the only thing that
is missing for me to go
through all of these courses.
But if you have the time, there
is some really cool resources
we're going to be sharing
with you about how
to learn machine learning.
But before that, we have
the cool thing of the week--
cool things of the week.
And the first one
is a new region.
We just announced on
May 10th a new region
in Northern Virginia.
And actually, I did not know
where northern Virginia was.
MARK MANDEL: You
had to look it up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, I had to.
For all of those out
there, Northern Virginia
is somewhere in the
east coast near DC.
And that's as much
as I'm going to say.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair enough.
I don't know any better.
I'm Australian.
I have no idea.
There you go.
It's on the east coast.
So it is US East 4.
So that's pretty cool.
We're kind of on a bit of a
roll with regions, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's very cool.
You're going to see that
for Washington DC, New
York, Boston,
Montreal, and Toronto,
it means that your latency
in return trip time
will be with reduced
in between 25% and 85%,
which is pretty awesome.
If you have some customers
in there around east coast,
this is a huge, huge
benefit for you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I'm just looking
through the product supported.
It is listed on the
blog post that we
will have in the show notes.
But it's pretty much
almost all of them--
everything from App Engine
to Compute Engine to Dataflow
to Data Store to Cloud
DNS and Cloud VPN.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
one that I don't see
is Big Table, for
instance, and Spanner.
But I'm sure that
will be coming soon.
So if you're not using
those, go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: And speaking
of those products,
specifically on the
compute side of things,
general availability is
now there for 64 core CPUs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is cool.
MARK MANDEL: So if you
have massive workloads
or just like making really
big machines, then we
can definitely do that for
you at a general availability
level, which is sort of cool.
And speaking of which, if
you go to the blog post,
there is a quote
there from our friend
Tim Kelton from Descartes
Labs and talking about what
they do with 64 core CPUs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And if you want to learn more
about what Descartes Labs do,
check out episode
number 41 where
we interview Tim
Kelton, which is
one of their Cloud architects.
Definitely an
interesting episode,
and we talk about how to
use very powerful computers
like this one, but also
how to make it cheaper
by using preemptable instances.
There you go.
And we have one more
cool thing of the week.
It is one blog post
that comes from--
MARK MANDEL: His name
is Alexander Holbreich.
I'm going to assume that's
how we pronounce it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: "Hol-brigh"?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Sure.
I've actually done a decent
job this time possibly.
Really love it when we can find
cool stuff from the community.
Either people send
it to us, or it
gets re-Tweeted by teammates.
If you have stuff,
please send it through.
But he wrote a
really cool article
about using Terraform with
Google Cloud Platform--
the steps that you need to go
through to get it all set up,
some of the gotchas that
can kind of catch you out
during the process, and
basically get you set up
and ready to go if Terraform is
your automation tool of choice,
if you want to create machines
and storage and all sorts
of other good stuff.
I'm all for automation.
Anything that
automates, I'm all for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
was going to say,
that I'm not shocked that
you're interested in Terraform,
knowing that your
favorite product ever
is Deployment Manager.
So yeah.
MARK MANDEL: As long as things
are automated, I am happy.
I don't mind how people do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
So yeah, go check it out.
It's a very interesting article.
So thanks, Alexander
Holbreich, for writing it.
So I guess it's time to go
talk to our friend Craig
Ganssle from Basecamp Networks.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that then.
So a few months ago in March
when we were at Cloud Next,
I had the distinct pleasure
of meeting up with a gentleman
by the name of Craig Ganssle.
Craig, how are you doing today?
CRAIG GANSSLE: I'm doing great.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: Very, very well.
We had a super
interesting conversation
when we were on the show
floor at Cloud Next.
So I basically was like, you
need to come on the podcast
and tell us about
all that we do.
But before we get sucked into
the company that you work for
and the really interesting
stuff that you get up to,
can you tell us a little
bit about who you are
and what you do and the
company you work for?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Sure, absolutely.
I am Craig Ganssle, as you said.
I am the founder and CEO
of Basecamp Networks.
And Basecamp Networks is a
innovative technology company
that works with wireless
infrastructures and software
development using
artificial intelligence
and machine learning,
specifically in agriculture.
But we do work in some verticals
outside of agriculture.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What were
you doing at Cloud Next?
How do you use the cloud?
You're talking
about agriculture,
you're talking about plants.
What is the technological
part of this?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Sure.
We built a product in 2013--
an application
called intelliSCOUT.
And intelliSCOUT is an
artificial intelligence
platform that uses
image recognition
to detect pathogens in plants
on crops and agriculture
in real time.
The entire thing lives in
the Google Cloud Platform.
And we love it living there.
It has had great results.
And being that it's
in the cloud like that
allows us to scale
dramatically around the world.
intelliSCOUT is being
used in multiple countries
around the world.
And it's used highly
in R&D environments
with large corporations to
do better trialing and better
production for seeds and
the performance of crops,
I guess we could say.
When seeds go in the ground
and we plant and then
everything grows in
the middle and then
we harvest in the end--
when everything's
growing in the middle,
people are trying to
capture data from the field
before we could potentially
have a crop that
gets affected by a disease
or we lose that crop.
And so intelliSCOUT takes
the actionable insights
from the field that would
normally take weeks or a month
even to diagnose and get back
in the hands of a farmer.
With intelliSCOUT, it
happens in minutes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
some time ago, we
interviewed Descartes Labs.
And they do
something really cool
where they're also
be able to identify
some problems like
forests and stuff
like that through
satellite images.
Is that how you do it?
What is the input
to your application?
CRAIG GANSSLE: So we don't
do anything with satellite
right now.
What we do is we
use mobile devices--
what people are already using--
and actually as well
with Google Glass, which
is how my entire vision
for intelliSCOUT began.
I was one of the early people
asked to come up to New York
and get Glass.
And that's really kind
of how it started.
So Google Glass, iOS right
now, coming soon on Android,
and also soon on drones.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So you're one of those
Google Glass explorers?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The pioneers?
Nice.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So just so I get this
right in my head,
so basically you have
people out in the field,
either using their mobile
phones or Google Glass,
taking photos of crops
and then sending that back
to some services that run
in the cloud or Google Cloud
Platform that then process
that and determine information
about it, such as yield or
disease or other such things.
Is that pretty much correct?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Yeah,
that's pretty much it.
It has some additional
automations.
In crop monitoring,
there are some things--
like, with corn, they will count
the kernels on an ear of corn
to help predict yield.
And today, a lot of times
they do that with a Sharpie.
Well, if you've ever stood out
in July in a field in Georgia,
it gets really hot.
And so what was one
of the first things
we did with Google Glass is now
you can take an ear of corn,
hold it up in front of Google
Glass or an iOS phone or tablet
and snap a picture,
and it counts
the kernels with over 97%
accuracy in about two seconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
That is probably higher
than humans when it's hot.
CRAIG GANSSLE: Yeah,
the average percentage
that people were accepting
in the ag industry
was about 72% to 86%.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, nice.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
CRAIG GANSSLE: So
we've increased that,
and we've narrowed the time
window in which it happens.
So it takes the picture, sends
everything up to the cloud,
runs the process,
comes back down
about two seconds with results.
MARK MANDEL: So
what powers that?
Is that TensorFlow?
Is that something else?
Is that some kind of
machine learning thing?
What's the deal there?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Yeah.
So we started with open CV, and
now we are using TensorFlow.
There's a lot of components
that we're doing--
Firebase, I think we're
using Pub/Sub and Kubernetes.
We're using a lot
of the Google Cloud
Platform-- the full stack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
let's concentrate first
on the part that, for me, is
the most exciting one, which
is the machine
learning side of it.
You say that you
started with open CV.
Could you tell a bit
to the audience that
doesn't know what open CV is?
And why were you using it?
And what made you
migrate to TensorFlow?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Sure.
I will answer that best as I
can without my chief developer.
But open CV is open
Computer Vision.
And that was a bit more of an
open source sort of practice
that we just started
messing around with.
TensorFlow-- it was just faster,
The way the algorithms sort of
compared the data
that was coming in.
And it was able to
train the machine
to learn the results
quicker, if that makes sense.
So taking a cataloged
library of imagery
and capturing multiple pictures,
you have to train the machine.
So first, you have to start
with kind of your zero base.
Hey, this is a healthy plant.
And then, this is
corn leaf blight,
and then this is corn
leaf blight pretty severe.
And this is corn leaf
blight really bad.
And TensorFlow managed
to take those images
and sort of process them a
little bit more seamlessly--
that the results became
far more accurate
when we took our
algorithms, mixed them
with TensorFlow
algorithms, and really
got the entire sequence running.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think that
it is pretty interesting,
because open CV is not
really machine learning.
I've used it before.
And it allows you to do things
like counting the kernels
in the corn, for instance.
It would be able to do that.
CRAIG GANSSLE: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
you need to write it.
Detecting something like
how healthy this plant is,
that sounds actually
pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: I was
going to ask, did you
have a catalog of imagery of
diseased corn or something
like that to train this against?
Did you have that prepared, or
did you have to go find that?
CRAIG GANSSLE:
That's a funny story.
No.
Actually, the answer
is no, we didn't.
And we searched.
We searched agriculture
universities,
other universities,
large seed corporations,
even the Library of Congress.
Nobody had properly
tagged images
of crops or the
pathogens or pests
that could infect
crops for all the ones
that we started working on.
So we had to really start
creating them ourselves.
And that's been a
very daunting task.
And that is also where
TensorFlow helped.
Where we were originally having
to capture thousands of images
to train the machine,
now we can probably
get away with 40 to 60 images to
get the machine trained to have
really good accuracy results.
But nobody really had anything.
People had images, but they
weren't cataloged properly.
They weren't tagged with, what
is this and what pathogen is it
and what's the severity level.
And severity level
has been really hard,
because that's
very much dependant
upon the subject matter experts.
So one pathologist might
say, hey, this is 30%.
Another might say, no, I
think it's more like 45%.
And so a couple of different
countries, including
the USDA and multiple
companies, have
been looking at
intelliSCOUT to possibly
be that first benchmark to
set a standard in an accuracy
setting--
a benchmark setting in the
industry-- because of the way
it's capturing information
and we're analyzing it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So something that
really surprised me was
you said that, well,
to train the model,
at the beginning,
you had to use thousands
of images, which is what
sounds normal to me, really.
When you are doing
deep learning,
you really need big data.
But then you say that
you went down to 40, 60.
What magic is this?
CRAIG GANSSLE: That's some of
the algorithms and the ways
that we internally have come
up with training the machine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds top secret.
CRAIG GANSSLE: Kind of, yeah.
Yeah, that falls under the
Intellectual Property Clause.
It also is very dependent upon
what disease we're looking at.
Some are very easily
detectable, and some are not.
And for the ones that
are not, we still
do sometimes need to
get up in higher images.
But it's really not in
the thousands anymore.
It can kind of just
be in the hundreds.
We built into the platform,
both in Google Glass
and on the iOS app,
a reticle design.
So when you launch the
camera, there's a reticle.
And when you line up
the leaf or the crop
of the plant in that
reticle, it filters out
a lot of the background
noise automatically.
So you're basically certain
to get a good picture
right from the get-go.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I know nothing
about agriculture.
But now I'm just
kind of curious,
because it popped into my head.
Do you do insects and stuff?
I don't know.
Are locusts still a problem?
I have no idea.
Is that a thing?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Yeah.
So that falls under the category
of pests, bugs and insects,
and working with entomologists.
Like, in corn, you have
sweet corn armyworm.
In cotton, you can
have boll weevil--
different pests that infest the
crop at either an early stage
or a late stage.
MARK MANDEL: You
talked a little bit
about some of the products
you're using at GCP.
Can you talk at least
a bit about some
of the platforms you're using?
You mentioned Kubernetes,
your Firebase.
Let's stick with
machine learning.
Did you use Kubernetes to help
train the TensorFlow models?
Did you use Cloud ML Engine?
What did you use there?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Yeah.
So the developers
are using Kubernetes
to satisfy the definitions
automatically with TensorFlow.
Load balancing, health
checks, and instance groups--
Cloud SQL.
Pub/Sub for production,
depending on some of the system
architecture.
Some of the others, I think I'd
have to get with the developers
to find out specifically how
they're using everything.
But yeah, we also are working
with a bit of the Lagom
framework.
But TensorFlow, probably one
of the biggest that we have.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sorry, what's
the framework you mentioned?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Lagom.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
do not know that.
Could you tell us a
little bit about it?
CRAIG GANSSLE: It allows
us to sort of push things
to production in real time.
MARK MANDEL: So I'll
ask this question then.
So why did you end up
choosing Google Cloud
Platform as your platform?
Were there particular features
or tools or platforms or things
that made your life easier
for what you were building?
CRAIG GANSSLE: So I have
three definitive reasons
for that, the first one being
we actually started in AWS
and it was not
user-friendly to work with,
and it crashed on us
a couple of times.
So we moved over to
Google Cloud Platform.
The interface is just far easier
to use and navigate through.
The connective
framework of things
like Kubernetes and Firebase
and the other things
that kind of plug in to GCP
were a whole lot easier to use.
And Basecamp Networks,
as a company,
has a longstanding
partnership with Google,
with the Glass Development
Team for Google Glass.
We're a G-suite
reseller and integrator.
So those kinds of things--
it just made sense to just keep
it all in the Google house.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
I'm wondering, since you cannot
share the magic about going
from thousands of images for
training to going to 40 to 60--
which is amazing, and I will ask
you once we're done recording--
could you share any other best
practices or pieces of advice
for other companies that might
be considering doing something
similar to what you did?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Sure.
Our Chief Solutions Architect,
Dr. Christian Kennedy,
he has a really good way
of explaining to people.
This is how we're explaining
the machine learning.
You're training a machine.
And so that data-- whatever
you're training it with--
is coming from somewhere.
In our situation, it's coming
from the expert knowledge
of pathologists and
entomologists in agriculture
and how they see pathogens
and pests affecting crops.
So as we train the
machine, we have
to go off of the best knowledge
that we get from them.
The methods of how
we're taking pictures--
and part of that reticle
design to make sure
that we're getting good
pictures-- making sure
that they are properly
tagged, they're
properly classified so that
our classifiers have the best
accuracy possible going in to
the original scan of training
that machine from
the very first time.
And I think that's really a big
key with any kind of machine
learning and even deep learning.
So sure, we're doing that "if
this, then that" component
with machine learning
in agriculture.
If you see this, then
it's corn leaf blight.
But then what do you do?
Then we get into the deep
learning of what is next,
and this is what you should
do from a spring in herbicide
or a pesticide.
If we catch things
earlier, we're
able to spray less
herbicides and pesticides.
That means the farmer can
have better crop outcome.
That means globally, we
can impact climate change,
because we're spraying
less in all of our farmland
around the world.
But all of this comes
from getting great data
to start with.
And so that's why intelliSCOUT,
we did not start by putting
this in the hands of just all
the farmers as a $5.00 app you
could download and subscribe
to, but more starting with
the large corporations
who have the pathologists,
the PhD talent in-house to give
us really good data to start
with so that we know
we're training the machine
at the most accurate levels of
severity and getting the best
possible classifiers for
identifying what we have
and what we want the
machine to recognize.
So it's all about really
good data to start with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
keeping on the data topic,
what kind of training
have you been doing?
Do you train the
models regularly?
Did you train them once,
and they're good enough now?
I guess that you keep on
getting more and more images.
Do you also use those
images that people
are using to detect if there
is some illness in their crops
to improve your own predictions?
CRAIG GANSSLE: Absolutely.
So that's kind of the big
factor with TensorFlow
is the more you use it, the
smarter it's going to get.
So we kind of train everything
once and really get it going.
And the more that it gets used,
the more it's getting trained.
And so it's getting smarter
the more it gets used.
Because even if somebody
takes an image and that image,
they want to have it classified
or have it identified, what
am I looking at here, that image
is also then repurposed and put
into the system as a classifier.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So one last question
on the same topic,
because I'm very curious--
so what happens if
someone takes an image
and you're not able
to classify correctly?
Does that happen?
Do you have some
experts in-house?
What is the flow in those cases?
CRAIG GANSSLE: It sort of
casts it off and alerts us
that we have an anomaly.
We have a situation
here with an image
that is not fitting
with the classifiers
that we've programmed
in the machine.
So if you're out scouting
corn for armyworm
and you take a picture
of southern rust,
the system's going to
say, that's not armyworm,
but I don't know
what it is, we need
to take a look at this image.
Then once we program and
train it on southern rust,
it will say, that's
not armyworm,
but that's southern rust.
So if it's something
new, it's going
to cast it off and alert
through the system and say,
it's not armyworm, but
I don't know what it is.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So now I'm also super curious,
from a practical level,
what has been the biggest
change, in regards to how
agricultural farming that
you've had under this program
has changed from what it was
previously, if that makes
sense?
CRAIG GANSSLE: How have we
impacted farming kind of?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
CRAIG GANSSLE: Going
back to whether it's
the app on a mobile device
or utilizing Google Glass,
part of what we want to be
able to do with intelliSCOUT,
as it gets smarter
and smarter and gains
more knowledge and more
crops and different diseases
and different pests, is
really unable smallholders
of the world.
We want to be able to
take this technology
and share it with people
in other countries--
so for example, in some
far remote areas of Africa
where their land is
not as rich as maybe it
is here in the United States.
And so every square acre of
land is very valuable to them.
And they want to
maximize what they
can grow off of that land
to its fullest potential.
So by being able to catch
diseases or pests far earlier
using intelliSCOUT--
by sending them
something like a pair of
Google Glass and they put it on
and they launch the
intelliSCOUT application
and they simply scan the
field and take pictures
and the results come back
in near real time with,
here's what's going on, and
then into that deep learning of,
here's what you need to do.
And so if you look at
something that would normally
take weeks or a month,
until you get those results,
depending on weather
patterns, your disease
could spread far more.
And back where it
originally started,
that could be just dead, gone,
and lost crop and lost yield.
So if we can capture
things in more real time,
then we can enable smallholders
with better knowledge.
They're able to grow
more, grow better food,
become much more sustainable.
So that's one way is
to just kind of enable
the education of
smallholders around the world
with better technology.
The other piece of
it is just, as I
say with the image library,
there wasn't anything for us
to start with.
And so we're building
that catalog library now
that will exist in agriculture.
MARK MANDEL: So you said
something really interesting
there that I think you kind
of slipped in, which was,
once you've got a diagnosis,
giving suggestions
on what people should do.
Is that something
you're doing now,
or is that a plan
for the future?
CRAIG GANSSLE: It's
something we're
doing now to a small extent.
We want to correlate even more
data from other data points
on the farm.
So intelliSCOUT
would be-- wherever
you're standing when
you take a field report,
it tells you where you were
and what the weather was
when you took that report.
So if you're standing in a field
and you take a picture of corn
and you're looking at
a particular disease,
we want to correlate data
that came from the machinery
from the day it was planted.
So the John Deere planter or
the AGCO planter or whatever--
when intelliSCOUT
takes the report,
it says, yeah, but I want to go
further and see when this was
planted, what was the spacing,
what was the compaction,
and from then till now, what's
that irrigation been like--
have we had a lot of rain, have
we had to manually irrigate
through pivots or other methods,
what's the nitrogen levels been
from then till now--
and really start pulling
data from other data
points on the farm
to make intelliSCOUT
smarter and smarter and get
into that deep learning.
That then allows us to get
into protective modeling.
And predictive modeling
could potentially
change the game for agriculture.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds very amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
unfortunately, we're
kind of running out of time.
But I wanted to give
you the opportunity
of letting us know if we
missed any interesting topics.
Everything you've
said was amazing.
Is there anything else
that you'd like to mention?
CRAIG GANSSLE: I don't think so.
You guys asked some really
good questions that kind of
explains it really well.
We enjoy being in
the Cloud platform.
That's working out
really well for us.
We do a lot with
Google in other areas.
We're glad.
This whole project
started with Google Glass,
which a lot of people are
like, oh, it's dead and gone.
And it's been doing some
wonderful things in enterprise.
And we're proud to be one
of those companies who
have kind of kept it going.
So thanks for having me.
I really appreciate it.
Glad we could tell the story
of what we're doing here.
And we'll see where it goes.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome, Craig.
Well, thank you so
much for joining us.
That was super,
super interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That was amazing.
Thank you.
CRAIG GANSSLE: Thanks a lot.
Appreciate it, guys.
MARK MANDEL: A huge thanks to
Craig from Basecamp Networks,
chatting with us about what
they do with machine learning
in the agriculture industry.
I love the super cool practical
application of Google Glass,
actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I thought
that was quite cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That was pretty cool.
Yeah.
For me, the coolest thing
is all the potential
that this technology has to
actually help people and help
countries.
The fact that your
plants get sick
can actually create
real problems.
So this technology is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, since we're talking
about machine learning,
why don't we segue nicely
into the question of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very nice segue.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Thank you.
It's always good when
you explain segues.
They work so much better.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So the question that
we received was, OK,
so I want to learn
machine learning,
where do I get started?
And especially, oh,
just go to university,
go to college, whatever--
those are options,
but they're, in general,
pretty expensive.
So instead, what we found was
three different courses that
are completely free and
available on the internet
and that you should check out.
The first one-- the one I
went through on Coursera.
And it is a very cool one,
especially because the teacher
is Andrew Ng.
And I think I
pronounced it correctly.
He used to be at Google.
Now I think he's at Baidu.
He's one of the geniuses
of machine learning.
And you can see him explaining
how machine learning works
starting from zero,
understanding what
are the basics from the
point of view of mathematics,
and moving into deep learning
and neural networks and all
of that.
It is really cool.
It's a very good place to start.
That's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: I
would second that.
I've done like a quarter of it.
Yeah, I didn't finish it.
I ran out of time.
But it is excellent.
It is absolutely excellent.
Totally free-- It's on Coursera.
I have a strange feeling--
I could be wrong--
that it's actually the first
course they had on Coursera.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I am not
sure, but it is possible.
It is possible.
It's a pretty old one, but
it's actually really good.
MARK MANDEL: It's amazing.
It's really from
fundamentals-- really enjoy it.
You have a second one
here that is from Udacity.
I haven't done that.
But it's also a deep
learning course.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's a deep learning
course by Google.
And basically, the
idea is, if you already
have the basics of
machine learning
and what you want
to learn is, OK,
so how do I do deep learning,
this course is by Google.
And it is taught by--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I am not
pronouncing that last name.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Vincent Vanhoucke.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems reasonable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
going to say with that.
And he's a principal
scientist at Google.
He works in the Brain Team.
So you're going to see
things like deep learning
and specifically how we use
it at Google-- also talking
about how TensorFlow works.
It is a pretty long course.
It says the timeline
is around three months.
But again, it's completely free.
And it's on Udacity.
So check it out.
We'll have it on the show notes.
And finally, there is
one more from Stanford.
And I have not taken this
course from Stanford,
but I took one a long time ago.
They're awesome.
You have all the videos, all
the notes, all the slides.
And this one's
specifically on how
to use TensorFlow for
deep learning research.
So this one is definitely
not an introductory course.
Don't go there trying to be
like, hey, I know some math,
I just want it--
MARK MANDEL: It'll be fine?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It will not be fine.
It will definitely hurt.
But if you already know
what machine learning is
and what you want
to learn is what
are the basics of TensorFlow--
like, what is a
tensor and how it
is implemented-- this
is the course that you
want to go through.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So it sounds like if
I don't know anything,
I should go to that
Coursera course.
If I'm sort of mid-level,
I go to that Udacity one.
Just But if I'm
already like, man,
I've got mad skills
in machine learning,
then I go and do the
Stanford one instead.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'd
say that that's correct.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right.
That's great.
Now I'm going to go
stare at these courses
and potentially do them maybe
at some point in the far future.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
The cool thing is,
Udacity and Coursera--
they have this mobile app
that allows you to download
and watch them later.
So yeah, you can actually watch
that while you're on a plane.
So yeah, that is really cool.
But yeah, then you need the time
to actually watch those videos.
MARK MANDEL: Now we should
also make note that episode 71,
we did do an episode on
Cloud ML with Yufeng Guo.
And we also did a TensorFlow
episode with Eli Bixby
that you're going to look up the
number for while I'm talking,
which goes through
TensorFlow and how it works
and how it can be applied
to machine learning as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And it was episode number 31--
"TensorFlow with Eli Bixby."
Very cool episode,
very interesting,
and actually, I think the
first one that we actually
put on YouTube.
MARK MANDEL: It is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And also, since we're
talking about that,
it's worth mentioning--
this could have been a
cool thing of the week.
The GPUs for Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
which is what we discussed
with Yufeng Guo on episode 71,
they're now general
availability.
So a little announcement--
so if you want to use GPUs,
now you can, even with
general availability
that comes with SLAs,
SLOs, and all the SLXs.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well, Francesc, thank
you again for joining me.
But what are you up to?
What are you doing?
Where are you going?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
finally back to San Francisco.
And by the time this
episode comes out,
Gopherfest will have been
a huge success on Monday,
or at least I hope so.
MARK MANDEL: I expect so.
I would expect no less.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But after that,
I will be going to Argentina.
And I will be speaking at a
Go meet-up in Buenos Aires--
"Bo-nis Air-is," pronounced with
Australian accent, apparently.
That will be on June 1st.
And on June 2nd, I will be there
for Google Cloud On-Board Latin
America, which is a
really cool event.
It is a training event.
You can go there and learn about
all the Google technologies.
And the cool thing is that
it is in Buenos Aires,
but it will be also live
streamed to all Latin America.
So we'll have a link
on the show so you
can follow the live stream.
And the live stream will
actually be in Spanish.
I'm going to be giving
talks in Spanish.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
That's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
What are you up to?
MARK MANDEL: When
this goes live,
I will be literally
probably almost on stage
at Nordic Games Conference,
talking about containers
and game servers and stuff.
Then I'll come back
for a little bit
and go on a bit of a vacation.
But I definitely want
to do a shout-out
to one particular event that
will be hosting at the Google
Launch Pad in San Francisco.
They actually do things all
across the United States,
as well as worldwide.
They're a program
called Girls Make Games.
They basically run game jams,
as well as mostly summer camps,
for girls that are
of the age from--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
said 11 to 17 before.
MARK MANDEL: 11 to 17, yes--
girls from the age of 11 to 17.
So they're going to be running
the SF1 in the Launch Pad
for a short period during that.
It's basically a
full program in which
girls get to learn how to
build games, deploy games.
It's really, really cool.
It's over the summer
period, around July 10th.
They have a variety of locations
across the United States
for the summer period
when kids are off school.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We'll have the link
in the show notes.
Maybe if you are a girl between
ages 11 to 17, check it out.
And if you know one of those,
check it out, too, and let
them know.
MARK MANDEL: No,
it's a great program.
I can't recommend
it highly enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, I guess
it's time to say goodbye.
But before that, why don't we
remind all of our listeners
how to get in touch with us?
MARK MANDEL: Certainly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we have web page.
MARK MANDEL: At GCPpodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have an email.
MARK MANDEL: Hello@GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: @GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We have Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: Slash
R slash GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We are on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: At the hash
podcast channel at Slack,
which can be found
at bit.ly/GCP-slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I'd say that's it.
MARK MANDEL: We have
Google+ at +GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I should
never forget Google+.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, thank you, again,
Francesc, for joining me
for yet another week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]